نحن الان على متن السفينه مايه واحد التي
كانت تحمل يوم امس العالم المالكي وقبض
عليها جهاز دعم الاستقرار وكانت محمله
باكثر من مليون لتر من الوقود كانت مجهزه
للتهريب خارج ليبيا هذه المشاهد الحصريه
تنفرد بها العربيه والحدث حيث نحن
اللاحدون الذين تمكنا من الوصول الى
السفينه وهي في عرض البحر
احببتوا عمليات التهريب اجاره عند ساعات
الفجر الاولى على بعد ما يقارب 20 ميلا من
شواطئ زوارا في اقصى الغرب الليبي وضبط
داخل السفينه ثمانيه اشخاص من الجنسيه
الهنديه قالوا حسب ما افادتنا به اداره
مكافحه الهجره والتوطين بجهاز دعم
الاستقرار انهم جاءوا من ملطه المسؤولون
هنا يقولون انهم اجبروا على ايقاف السفينه
في ارض البحر وعدم دخولها للمرسى لانه غير
معدل لرسوله سفن بهذا الحجم وهم الان
يعملون على استكمال الاجراءات وتسليها الى
جهات الاتصال
نوقفوا فيه ونطلبوا من اجراءاته ولما تم
استيقافها طلعت
سفينه مالطيه ما دخول غير شرعي مستباح
للمياه الدوله الليبيه من جميع الاماكن
تهريب الوقود الى اوروبا ودول الجوار
يستنزف والاقتصاد الليبيه بشكل مستمر فيما
يقدر الانفاق على دعم المحروقات سنويا من
الدوله
ما يعادل مليارين دولار امريكي تقريبا